そう今私ばエアお掃除をしているふーん
とても葉っぱてるでね私王家セルファ
親ありがとう前 funny いわたし掃除がんばるー
ブーバーれ
ああああああああああっ
今日は誰かもよあのあれですディズニーの映画どんなにかキャラが突然あの
いけないミュージカルで入り出すような
肝臓イメージしましたなんではありませんじゃあねちょっと部屋の掃除をして部屋が
きれいになったんだけども
ほうきを買いましたな号機ですねこれぐらいならですね
ペナ俺はと思い出したんだ伯耆原んそ
高校思えばやってて私かなんかその学校のさあその過ごしの時間に僕はもう
同時大嫌いなんで先生くると聞いが一つしてなかったんですけども手のひらに後方機を
立てて来てバランスを取りますこれはこんなこの状態でこの状態を何秒できるかって
いうねああ
メガネは今日はねいかに俺がねこの4大規模なんですよね長い時間というかっていうの
を北に教えようトッポ思う
裁判後今日はねあんまり媚びないでない理由もパパ結果ですよ
結果はすべてという意味でタイマー図りますこれから自分でやってると図れる患者いき
ます
じゃいきますが存在します妖艶へ待っておれこれ自分しといてするもんじゃないでしょ
自分で襲って自分で食べればなぜた証拠差が出ると思います
良いぞ
天才天才
こうゆうかんこういう感じです
平均はね大体どうだも全然わかんないけど高安定感
生まれ持った才能っていうかねそれだかあるんですよねー
こそ余裕を見せつつねー
ていこうと思います全然時間がわかりません
マカラクね世間話でも
一応ああっお腹痛いミスった音が入ったちょっとお腹が痛かったでもう1回
ハーンな画面の外でたらチートとか言ってるからあんまり出ないようにしましょうさあ
45秒でした
ん
こんなはずじゃないんだよマンていく恋のあって
ああああああああ
用意したぞ
ターリン大御心なぁトビア本当に最後
これキャッチで最後1人5回までなようですけど
を
これ本この本気だ
これは本気です
して捉える放棄は何を持っている箒が何を持っている
凰稀は何が起こっている放棄の気持ちになる方気もしない方位の気持ちになる
大きな気持ちになりは落ち着きまして凰稀はねまっすぐになりたいんだ草創期以降
まっすぐだ言っ27秒でしょ
完全にねぇ
ちょっと弱まってるんですけど僕の記録46秒くらい
ぜひね学校とかで
掃除する機会がある人やってみちゃ
いいやってみてはいかがでしょうか俺の放置ませんキロ気抜いて皆
じゃ
しています